oh no why is he appearing while in
surgery and how did he get this laptop
in there
oh mr green so it seems that appearing
in court as a cat is not the worst thing
that you can do if you have a telephonic
court appearance
this doctor appeared in court while
actually in surgery let's watch
it kind of looks like you're in an
operating room right now i am sir i'm in
operating room yes i'm available for
trial go right ahead
no you're not available if you're
actually in surgery so
unless i'm mistaken i'm seeing a
defendant that's in the middle of an
operating room appearing to be actively
engaged in providing services to a
patient
is that correct mr greene yes sir i mean
the judge to his credit is handling this
with poise
you should give the court the respect
but also you should give your patient
respect this might be a hip violation if
you didn't get consent to
videotape while in surgery and also
you're endangering a patient's life and
it's all recorded this is this is total
insanity i wouldn't be surprised if this
patient
saw him in court just like i'll see you
in court if you don't subscribe